Kylie baby number two congratulations
thank you so do we have a name no we
have some um we have some really strong
options but we haven't officially
changed we have some placeholders so
before I officially change it I just
want to be sure well Kylie Jenner
revealed earlier this month that she and
Travis Scott officially named their
almost one-year-old son air like the air
we breathe with an e at the end I love
it now the reality star is proving she
has a sense of humor when it comes to
all the jokes people are making about
the name Choice online
water
Earth
fire
air
a tick tock Creator recently shared that
dramatic clip alongside the text Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott deciding on a
baby name and Kylie she swooped into the
comments dropping two crying laughing
emojis
meanwhile others were quick to point out
that air is a common Arabic expression
translation
my penis
so crazy of course baby air was
originally named wolf Webster a name
Choice Kylie says she made in a panic
before leaving the hospital why not wolf
and what is the name wolf was never on
our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested
I liked the name I don't think anything
I still like this I love it I love it I
like wolf I just wasn't him we really
didn't have a name I just thought it was
gonna just come to us when we saw him
you know 24 hours before we had to sign
the birth certificate or else they just
you know register him as without a name
and he doesn't get a Social Security
number and like the whole thing oh no so
I felt the pressure to choose a name and
then Chloe said like the day before we
signed like what about wolf and I was
like oh I like the WWE like so we just
did Wolf Webster in that moment and
right after I signed the birth
certificate I was like what did I just
do
Kylie and Travis waited almost a year to
make the big name reveal and opened up
about the whole thing on the Family's
Hulu series The Kardashians what are we
gonna do about the name have you thought
any more about that yeah I think we know
his official name I'm not gonna announce
it yet because God forbid we change it
again Travis actually still changes his
name a few times he'll come back and be
like I really like this name and then
for the day he'll call him that and I'm
like
we can't do this again Kylie and Travis
are also parents to an almost
five-year-old daughter stormy
[Music]
and whileosaurus recently told E.T that
Kylie and Travis are on a break they
continue to co-parent the source adding
quote although they aren't together
right now it doesn't mean it's over for
good
[Music]
thank you